hello and welcome to the watch my name
is chris ryan i am an editor at
theringer.com and joining me on the
other line also known as hans christian
anderfuck it's andy grew
[Music]
it's our post season finale succession
podcast we've come to the end of the
road
all roads lead to tuscany or or this
gorgeous uh italian village is it not
tuscany is that where you're going it's
tuscany no i was just going to say there
are some connective waterways that might
take you to um in and out of swiss
territory yeah so i'm just saying it's
not like we're stranded there there's
decent wi-fi i don't know what jesse
armstrong as a brit you know and they're
they're on the outside looking in in
europe now but he seems to be collapsing
some space here in the season finale
where i'm like uh okay so we're in
switzerland but now we're in italy but
now we're
call michael mann those are the real go
fast boats so there's two directions to
go in here uh there is the very end of
the episode which is what i will uh
from now on be referring to as the tom
father uh and then there is the opening
of the episode which answers all the
questions that we've been asking one
another for about six and a half days
about kendall uh
we can go in either direction or we can
start generally speaking about how you
felt about the episode it's dealer's
choice i know the answer also you're the
dealer um so it's it's your choice
expert at gambling um
we're going to start at the beginning
and
here's what i what i want to say
guys
we gotta pay attention to the shows
we're watching
three seasons in shows tell us what they
are
and like the great michelle obama said
when people tell you who they are
listen to them yeah you know what i mean
look we all had a lot of fun you know
what i mean over the last week it was
all it was all screens and up the ass in
logan's words like it was it was like
the old glory days of prestige tv on the
internet and we all had a great time
uh speculating having fun
sifting through the metadata as they
would say in the gojo c-suite right
about like when the new yorker drops
profiles of jeremy strong and the hbo
marketing team
you know making sure we don't have
screeners and the person who found the
poem that linked the three season finale
titles oh my god that was awesome um
great what a great great great reddit is
you know just like generally
scholarships in my experience it's
mostly about british poetry
so i don't see the problem um
but
and and by the way it went fast like i
i'll say that you know we are veterans
of the six days between wars that used
to erupt during breaking bad episodes or
game of thrones seasons etc etc
in retrospect i mean if you can be in
retrospect for the last six seven days
the speed with which the succession
discourse went from hmm that was kind of
a moody ending to an episode i think
i'll go have a snack to
he is a corpse
floating in italy and how does one have
a left
how does one get a body back to newark
international yeah right that was
wild and
i think that it might be it'll i'm very
interested to see
you know we're recording this
immediately after watching the episode
uh 7 p.m on the west coast uh but i'm
very interested to see what the
discourse is because
i think that some of the audience
members they were expecting a scalp they
were expecting a body you could call you
you're looking right at me call me by my
name you want me to at you yeah just at
me i was i was like that dude is dead i
was like this 100 like this is a perfect
ending for this character i wasn't doing
it because i was bloodthirsty i wasn't
doing it because i was like he's he's
rob stark i was doing this because i was
like they ended the character he has
tried multiple times they had the final
conversation he can't get free his guilt
they ended that version of the character
now
i do think there's a fun case to be made
if we go back through some of the
episodes like yeah in a way kendall did
die in that episode or at least that
version of him and we'll see what
emerges going forward there were
certainly some interesting tectonic
shifts in this episode but look i mean
this is the show this is what it has
been um in ways large and small
the narrative engine of succession has
always been about the moth circling the
flame and they keep circling and they
keep circling and they keep circling the
show does not give you
the scalps
this is the closest it's going to get to
the red wedding and there's a case to be
made that this was the red wedding for
the roy family and you know we're
definitely going to get to it but
uh
succession doesn't give us doesn't give
you bodies on the floor it gives you
bore on the floor sure you know and and
i'll say
that
for
are there legitimate frustrations to be
voiced about some of the
characterizations you know circling like
is there hope for kendall is there a
plan is there a different version of him
that we're going to see etc etc but
i came out of watching this episode and
i thought this was an excellent
rip-roaring good time great entertaining
succession episode that took the show to
a place that i'm very excited to see
going forward but my first reaction
is
i'm really glad to be in the hands of a
showrunner who is very confident in the
show he is interested in making and
continues to make it now he was not like
he was bowing to pressure he wrote these
scripts two years ago and they shot this
months ago so it's not like he was
sweating what the internet reaction was
going to be or what uh red meat the hbo
marketing team threw everyone in terms
of what there was going to be he can't
control that reaction but
i was pleased
that the show didn't deviate because
this is the show that i like and i
enjoyed it yeah i
look i in no way am i holding any of the
um
the close magic going on that they did
in between the end of the last episode
and the beginning of this episode
against anybody like i'm not even
holding it against hbo or anything like
that it's not like i felt duped as the
week went on i was
probably more along the lines of what
what you're saying like where it was
like i was pretty convinced on uh last
sunday's show that he had died i was
actually think that the reason why i was
convinced was not because i did any
like hard work on piecing together
all the reasons why that was going to be
in terms of like whether or not he
appears at the wedding or not it was
really just because dramatically and
narratively it felt like uh a genuinely
surprising
somehow fitting end to that character
not that i was true and then um
as the week went on i think i was a
little bit more and more
like wait a second you know like and i
think that i think i talked myself out
of it by the time so that when i turned
on the episode tonight and about 30 40
seconds in he's he's
logan is sitting with iverson and
reading him the the children's book and
he just says you know he's going to be
okay or whatever and it becomes quickly
apparent that that not only has he lived
through this possible suicide attempt
possible just passing out in a pool
um
but that he is kind of now you know in
the in the opening stages of this
episode reverts back to form you know
what i mean he has like a shaky point
where he's drinking the italian gatorade
but then kind of comes in and he's like
i'm putting my entire all my papers up
on instagram and you're like oh yeah
is that what it's called what's that
gatorade
that's right um limoncello flavored uh
and
i think that until that scene
the confession scene
there was like i i basically
i was like i kind of wish that that they
had gone through with it if that had
been in play i wonder whether it ever
was i wonder how sincerely that it was
being kicked around whether or not that
should be the end of the character
and then you get to the confession scene
which is basically shot like an
antonioni movie in this like abandoned
party amazing a village back by the
trash yeah wide shots of um
of the three siblings standing outside
of these these buildings and kendall
watching people
doing the job like the kind of jobs of
the person that he
allowed to die or killed or however you
want to view it and
i just thought
it was so amazing to
watch
in real time not only a just a
phenomenal piece of dramatic writing
comic writing and performing
but the actual philosophical debate set
up in the new yorker profile about
jeremy strong about yes
yes is this show a tragedy or is this
show a comedy and it's both
but to watch it be both
in the most extreme ways at the same
time and watch jeremy strong
pretty much go [ __ ] full dog day
afternoon
and just win another emmy sitting there
on the ground yep and kieran colkin
who's probably the real mvp of this
season yep insisting on and i'm sure you
know obviously following the script but
that character and that performance
insisting on no i'm gonna keep making
jokes about how bad the service was at
shiv's wedding because kendall killed a
waiter and joke joke joke joke up until
the very last second and then like right
when there's a rip cord being pulled
shiv's like well we gotta go it's back
to business so i thought that that was
just an amazing scene and it said a lot
about succession
i couldn't agree more
um
let's start with that scene
it was an amazing scene it was
beautifully composed it was beautifully
shot it was
dramatic it was emotional you see in
this scene beautiful scene amazing
wonderful wonderful can i interest you
in a trip to italy they take their trash
out on wednesdays during the wedding
it's amazing lovely properties in italy
uh
it was
worth it we earned uh we earned that
scene
and
watching it here's here was my thought
i'm really glad jeremy strong's on this
show yeah i'm really glad he's staying
on the show i'm really glad that where
whatever process he has to go through
to get to a place whether it's as
wonderful as jessica chastain tweets
that it is or whether it is as
challenging to be around as some of the
subtext in the new yorker article seemed
to suggest that it was not my business i
don't work on that show you know what i
mean i i don't have to ad those scenes i
don't know i'm not in the makeup trailer
trying to like make sure people don't
cross paths who cares
it is a gift to see him act and play
this character and i'm thrilled that
he'll get to do it for a longer time
and
let's also continue to praise
jesse armstrong and his writers and mark
milo the director because they run right
at
the issues that could be considered
problems the fact that jeremy strong and
kieran culkin are giving performances
that at times could potentially be in
completely other shows yeah they're
right and they are alone together and
each of them finds the others
companionship in that moment
excruciating not the actors the
characters the actors too who knows not
our business doesn't matter they are
harnessing the producers and writers
the inherent tension in their acting
styles
and making the show better because of it
and that is what the show does best and
it's a it's that level of
yeah we're talking about the content
that we're seeing great scene crackling
scene agonizing scene but we're also
talking about how smart everyone is
structurally managerially to allow that
to happen and i loved it and
circling back to the first point
you know i i think one of the reasons
why succession might frustrate some
people and i think that it's clear that
this season frustrated more people
than it has in the past part of that
just might be a factor of it's more
popular than it was in the past part of
that might be a factor of the pandemic
delay as we talked about um in the weeks
leading up to the season three premiere
boosted the show's profile and its
importance to a really really
wild degree potentially even untenable
degree of just almost like the show
itself is a celebrity and everyone's
talking about it and thinking about it
um
so i think there was a little bit of a
potential mr uh
misconnection or lack of connection
between the audience and what the and
what and what the show is but one thing
that is invariably true is that we look
to scripted entertainment and fiction to
go there to show us the big things that
we don't often see in our lives you know
whether they're like godzilla's
attacking cities or
uh you know knights in armor cursing and
killing dragons or selling meth or all
these things or something people
particularly unburdening themselves of
the biggest secret in their life well
that's what i want to get to though i
think the thing that succession does
very well that might confound some
viewer expectations and i don't even
mean some viewers in the like the the
famous emily nussbaumer in the new
yorker talking about breaking bads quote
bad fans the ones who wanted walter to
win or wanted tony soprano to whack more
people i don't mean that i just mean
that
we are conditioned and sometimes with
good reason because we like watching
people know kung fu in movies
to expect to see dramatic
the most dramatic exclamation point
underlined version of a story but in
life
the most catastrophic thing even if it's
what we expect or live our lives in fear
of rarely happens
what often happens is people are pushed
to a bottom that they think is the
bottom or a brink that they think is
their limit and then they have to go
have breakfast the next morning with the
people who saw them do it
and that provides its own kind of drama
and it's a smaller bore you know
certainly very uncomfortable drama but
in that way succession is mirroring the
kind of emotional frustrations of our
lives even you know whether we are super
rich or decidedly in our case in most
listeners case not
um
and i'll i'm always grateful for that
honestly i'm i'm grateful for the fact
that you are correct as a dramatic
character kendall roy is done he's used
up he's tossed away he's cellophane
rapper he's done
but life doesn't work like that he's
just still hang dogging around man and
what did it get us in this episode it
got us a pretty raw unburdening a
catharsis
and
the power of that moment when you're
just like what the the most powerful
line to me is when he said it's it's so
[ __ ] lonely yeah he's so
lovely and they all are every line he
had in that speech was
was was pretty heartbreaking and then
you juxtapose it with the fact that
his siblings won't give him anything
back in return shiv's obviously very
comforting but is immediately beckoned
away by a phone call
and roman is doing the fascists are cool
but not thing but about
this kid's life where he's just like
well you tried you know i would have
been out of there like a tabby you know
in the bath you know and and you know
you're practically a hero and like who
hasn't killed a kid and all this like
he's basically doing his version of
saying
you're gonna be okay and i thought that
that was like it's basically i don't i
know that you and i can sometimes get a
little bit immersed in the uh like the
sort of like what does this mean as tv
tv but you know kendall using one of the
most used tropes
in tv anti-hero dom which is i'm a bad
person you know this kind of
self-awareness to be like i am not the
hero here usually comes with that
character doing something very heroic or
trying to totally solve themselves of
of all the sins that they've committed
and and uh because this isn't um
low winter sun my perpetual i'm not a
bad man punching bag which no one cares
about anymore amc canceled it years ago
so apologies to all involved everyone
did their best stevie it's hard um
uh
roman's response is is kind of the right
one
nobody's anything everybody's we all in
a way i mean this is what's so crazy and
great about the show when he's like
we've all killed a kid i mean um no
we haven't
but in the most hundred thousand foot
macro version of talking to someone who
is just buried alive in a shame spiral
uh-huh
yeah we've all done terror we are all
terrible it's not one or the other and
he seems to think that it is and
one of the reasons why i think this
episode was super significant in the
life cycle of the show i mean all season
finales are overly significant but one
of the reasons why i think this is it's
not just because it definitively
declared to the world what the show is
and i think people will listen now you
know what it's going to be about and
what it's interested in doing
was that it really
drew a bright line around something that
i think the show has always always
animated the show which is what what is
the fundamental difference
between family or emotional
relationships like family and business
and
there are many there are many
differences and one of them might be
what roman you know insanely and blindly
and optimistically calls love but really
what i think the show has demonstrated
is that what family allows or encourages
is repeated
not just bad behavior but repeatedly
running
at something like like charlie brown in
the football
because the disappointment you feel when
you don't get what you want from someone
when there's a mismatch that familiarity
is at least reassuring sure at least you
know you're going to be disappointed at
least you know and you're you're going
to get the what is the shiv and rome
just kept touching his head like they're
like this is what humans do they touch
heads to make you feel better no they
don't i'm performing the difference
forming love here yeah right yes and
what business is
ultimately is [ __ ] just raw fanged
capitalism this is works
this doesn't work [ __ ] off right they're
right and the power to me of where the
episode ended and where i know we're all
over the place we should re we should
tick-tock through it and i don't mean do
a funny dance in 45 seconds i believe
that's what that means um
is that at the end they're just
scrabbling kids they're pathetic and
logan's right
and jerry's right
that is what they should do it's a good
deal what do you think
of
so the one of the things that was so
powerful about episode 8 and it's not
that this
it's not that the achievements of
episode 8 are in any way negated by what
happens in episode nine but what do you
think about how for instance the end of
episode eight were at least led to
believe or put in the headspace that
um
shiv blows up roman
to kind of seize her own role there uh
roman's in trouble but at least is now
diminished in his father's eyes yeah and
uh they basically like exi like they
ostracize jerry immediately and shiv
does that whole thing about like you
know would you like to make a formal
complaint and it seems almost like jerry
is walking out with a cardboard box of
their belongings i mean she isn't
she isn't literally doing that but
figuratively it's like she's walking
down that hallway she has been
kind of shut out and then
she's just in you know she's just
playing monopoly or she's right by the
table while they're playing monopoly in
the in the second scene of the next
episode do you do you find that they're
do you find that the cause and effect
chain in this season or in this episode
necessarily was it all
uh broken or am i am i just i and i'm
really asking because i'm curious what
your take was or whether i'm i'm
watching this a little bit too much like
it's colombo or something yeah i mean i
think that
without question there is an element of
episodic television at play in the way
succession breaks a season right like
those are dramatic moments and then like
the raid the the raid on the office that
was a dramatic place to end an episode
earlier this season did it have
consequences not really
but you know it is a
right i think they're probably past
studio and network notes at this point
but that is the stuff that you get in
notes being like can we have a punchier
act out um and it's really and when you
get notes like that it's really
especially for the weekly model
and actually for all models because the
binge model is used needs to get them to
keep watching immediately it's just how
can we keep it going it's a problem
you'll solve the next day in terms of
how i reacted to it
structurally and as a fan of the show
and of the season it didn't bother me
because what this
episode revealed really plainly and i
think it's something people have been
uh chirping about occasionally in the
margins which is
these kids are bad at this like they're
being indulged you know
and i think that what this episode made
plain i loved the way it happened where
they're all at the wedding and suddenly
they realize they are completely not in
the
they're not crossing anything they're
not on the inside track yeah they're not
inside nor nor should they be
they are in logan's words [ __ ]
pedestrians and he weight was wasting
time playing little power games because
that's what gets him off
with them up to this point
but
we are again we are not inside of logan
at all anymore this season and i wonder
if that will change next season i'd be
interested in that but one thing that i
i think it would be possible to watch
this season
do a logan re-watch of the season do
your best to see his eyes and what he's
seeing and i think you could make the
case that what the season was about was
the dominoes falling that each one of
his children disappointed him so
profoundly and finally
that what else was he going to do he
gave them rope and they used it to give
each other rat tails you know it
there is no logical version of this
where they deserve anything more than
what they've gotten from a financial
stance it's not a rooting interest kind
of thing and you know it's interesting
that you mentioned doing a brian cox
logan rewatch of the season because i
think it would be
educational to do the same for matthew
mcfadyen uh
and tom you know like yes and and
watching
his
you know obviously this this this
episode was a matter somewhat of
opportunity but i think that he had been
very open to that opportunity for at
least the duration of his time in italy
after the the sex dirty talk and
the agonizing uh frozen embryos speech
and
i think that um
you know there had been some speculation
like tom's wearing a wire or tom's gonna
do this or tom's gonna do that so it
wasn't out of nowhere and i think that
as as that episode kind of plays out and
when tom gets that phone call from shiv
and she's just like sure you're high but
like i have other [ __ ] things to talk
about yep
that's where the the knife goes in
and then on a wider scale if you look at
it in the totality of all succession
episodes what does logan respond to he
responds to killers yeah and tom
has already thrown himself on the
funeral pyro once when he goes up to
logan and says like if you need a head
you know if you need a skull take mine
and then he says how about i
betray your daughter who's trying to
betray you and he was like well nothing
would make me happier
one of the kind of brilliant judo moves
of this season was that we were so
inside
the kids
that we lost sight of the larger game
and i think that was very very very much
um very much intentional
if you think about it
the characters who are at the top at the
end of this season
logan
tom
uh
jerry greg greg greg's about to be the
the king of luxembourg craig is the k
he's going to be king of the defunct
throne of italy i mean not bad for her
come up
one thing that those characters have in
common is that when people say things to
them they listen yeah
they listen and they adjust accordingly
one thing that unites all four roy
children
is they don't listen at all and they
don't learn it all and you know i think
there's a case to be made maybe not in
an immediate reaction podcast but in a
longer think piece
i mean these kids are abused
now that's a very heavy word and they
are incredibly rich and privileged and
i'm not interested in opening up that
particular can of worms but in terms of
how they respond to things they just got
decapitated by their parents yes they're
yeah they're abused and and
the way they speak to each other you
know the circular language the circular
firing squad like and none of it matters
they're playing monopoly again the next
day because they're playing right
none of it matters none of it means
anything
because they're they believe
shockingly up until the very last moment
that their position is secure that
they're special that they're you know or
something
they're not
they're not playing they're playing a
game that is not the same game the other
people who have had other life
experience or who have struggled or who
understand what's actually going on is
playing and they're all
they all lose yeah and
you know this is another moment of of
tipping of the cap even though you're
the only one wearing a hat tonight like
how to have
for a moment like that to land
for the emotion that sarah snook is
playing in that moment and what kieran
culkin is doing and how jeremy strong is
like
almost blanked out like he's already
played this movie in his head buddhist
monk in this yeah he's just like i'm
like almost beyond like emotional
reaction to these situations
he understands failure from the inside
in a different way now like but for that
to be an empathetic
moment to be
an emotional gut punch for the audience
that's that's some high-level
storytelling jiu-jitsu there that's
pretty impressive and it feels right
that is right yeah the most succession
moment of the entire night or the entire
season maybe is the fact that there's a
moment right before the very last shot
where it actually almost is the end of
the godfather you know tom's outside
logan pats him on the back and you see
him through the door frame and you're
almost like holy [ __ ] are they going to
close the door on the kids because that
would be a [ __ ] that's that's how the
godfather ends
and what happens is even
more breathtaking in some ways because
tom goes in and kisses his wife on the
top of the head and is kind of like
what's wrong like what's up he
is finally on the other side of it he is
now a killer and
he is doing what
has been modeled for him he is
performing a marriage which is what
shiv's been doing from the beginning but
now all pieces of
old-fashioned midwestern human thinking
she was ready to sell him into prison
you know yes and
you know make these sort of gestures
towards sure yeah when you get out when
you get out
but in the meantime was planning for her
own future yeah he absolutely did
did exactly to shiv what shiv had done
to him for sure
and i think it's i'm glad you mentioned
that before that there was again it's
like just trying to like focus on like
the show tells you what it is especially
after at least one season and it tells
you how to watch it
and
tom
tom's emotional state not just the
precarity of his professional or um you
know his incar his carceral status right
was
very important this season
it was very important this season
but this isn't mayor of kingstown he's
not wearing a wire
what he's doing is listening should we
do should we just do make sound pod now
every sunday night going forward during
the holidays starting 7 50 p.m sunday i
think this is for the best um
this is how that plays out so people
were picking up the right
radio signals right but kind of
forgetting
a kind of forgetting what the show is i
think but also b we're not and we
shouldn't be
thinking on the creative level of the
people in charge of the show
just a pause to say that
we didn't know what was going to happen
this episode
no one i think correctly predicted what
was going to happen this episode that's
a good thing we're not chumps we're not
suckers people watching the show who
thought one thing was going to happen
for sure
relax man go into it be like roman on
that speedboat racing him back to his
mom's second or third or whatever
wedding you know what i mean drum on the
roof and let the wind go through your
hair this is what we watch it for it's
great so
here's a here's an interesting point
that kind of only occurred to me as as i
was watching the credits and as we were
getting ready to record
what are we even fighting for anymore
because like the the win you know he's
like you [ __ ] pedestrians and
he basically
gets peter munion into the house of
lords or the house of commons or
something and
and so
caroline re-does her divorce on the fly
giving logan control of the holding
company
but
that's not his company anymore you know
like that this i i i think it would be
amazing if they are able to find time
for alexander skarsgard to continue to
be on this show because he is i'm sure
he he really brings a cool energy and a
different energy and i i thought his
scene with logan was awesome you know
but
i don't you know it's it'll be
incredibly interesting going forward
it's like if you're the kids it's like
okay so we lost
what nothing like we lost being part of
this thing that we were eventually going
to get cut out of anyway
yeah and so
what's next season is roman working at
sabaro like what like like is it just
pick up six months later
that's right they're doing like the
office style confessional interviews
from their new lives and being like yeah
this is fine this is fine
um
look i i think that for as much as we
talk about how jesse armstrong is not a
conventional tv thinker or plotter at
least not in terms of the the american
heavy lift drama that we've experienced
over the last few decades he does
subscribe to the push all your chips
into the table at the end of the season
like that is absolutely something he
believes in um he's now three for three
on kind of devastating status quo
altering
final not just episodes final moments
right
um
that's their problem and i'm thrilled uh
it's up they're gonna have to figure
this out what it's gonna be going
forward i think that this makes
a lot of sense look it answers a lot of
the things the questions that people
were asking one of the reasons people us
included were like well kendall might
die because as you said he might be he
might be done in terms of what you can
do with his character going forward in
the current setup
um late breaking at the end of the week
um
i was talking to people who
who weren't just galaxy braining it made
a very strong case that actually the
kendall stuff was a misdirect logan was
going to die this is going to be brian
cox's last episode because if you think
about it where did you hear that i mean
like you have to say it was from
anything particularly but did you you
had conversations like that a particular
and i'll ask permission for thursday's
show if i can name a particular emmy
award-winning showrunner was like this
is what's going to happen david e kelly
told you david he's the ghost of steven
bochko visited me
um
uh
basically
in a really smart with a really smart
point of a point which is basically like
yeah think about it we're all saying
kendall is in this person's term arced
out
like what else is there to do but really
logan is because what other moves does
logan have and we've also the season
completely retreated from his pov
so
that all makes sense i i think that this
is the right move for this show because
it pulls the ground out from everybody
it makes them run in an interesting way
the one reason we maybe should have seen
it coming is this show is completely
fictional um although sometimes it's
horrifyingly close to home on both
emotional and geopolitical
on an emotional and geopolitical level
but
and i don't know all the details of how
this went down but rupert murdoch
sold his [ __ ] to disney yeah you know
what i mean he was just like this is the
right deal for the right moment we can't
do that and i don't want to do it
anymore so i know that my sons have been
you know
tap dancing like michigan j frog for the
last 30 years but nah this is
this is right
this is right i can
i i you know i don't i actually i mean
literally i know nothing about james and
lachlan murdoch and their psychologies
and their relationship with their father
or whatever but i do know that uh
rupert murdoch
was more comfortable sitting in a room
with bob iger in getting this [ __ ] done
then he was you know just kind of like
passing the buck to his children and
that was what that moment was skarsgard
was and i think that
again i don't know the casting decisions
but it feels like skarsgard is main cast
next season on this show also fun by the
way that we spent a bunch of time in the
off season and season being like you
know sana lathan and and adrian brody et
cetera et cetera peter riegert for some
of us were excited about that and uh
they didn't all pop some were kind of
like vanity one one episode
turns they could all come back in the
succession expanded universe they might
come back but one of them was gonna
stick and i think that's i think to your
point yeah they picked the right one it
it's very de-centering and kind of
um discomforting in a great way for the
characters and i think that's for the
drama speaking of sticking
all right let me pitch you on season uh
for succession yeah man flash forward 25
years yes and uh logan roy's maca root
has graduated college
is ready to take over
his shares of gojo
skarsgard lucas lucas is living in the
cloud he's been digitized into ai uh
he's just a pure nft it's dev season two
and kendall is now jeremy strong's like
i'll come back and play kendall if i get
to go
like full johnny knoxville and jackass
at the guy at the gas station like all
old man makeup oh my god he would do it
i mean the new yorker did mention that
as kendall he dyes his graying hair
right so i feel like he just wants to
let it go but it'd be natural man
yeah i i'm uh
i'm in on that i mean i'm really sure
speaking of his uh his his method acting
and and uh yeah you know i'm sure i'm
i'm probably wrong and i'm also about 10
years
out of practice myself but
he did not look like a very natural
smoker
sparking out that american spirit i
thought it was like an awkward first
puff you know i wondered about that
actually because i was watching it and
thank god because i'd like him to be as
healthy as possible and everything i'm
just saying
at that moment as a non-smoker i didn't
critique the the the style
i actually was like
i bet
jeremy strong
started smoking american spirits
six months prior to this when he got the
scripts the first time before covent
shut it down yeah just for that moment
so you'd have it accurately
you mentioned the the maca or the
whatever it is the the the root smashing
walnuts yeah he's smashing walnuts for
the siege
um
i i
that was such a it was very funny um
and
but it was also
it was part and parcel of the larger
momentum of the episode which was to
i mean this is a term that the episode
uses so well to completely not just
destabilize but eradicate the children's
position
because
again the show has kind of smartly
adopted their povs a bunch we're like
well kendall's more complicated than he
seems and maybe he's his heart in the
right place is in the right place or a
roman seems like a fuck-up but boy he
certainly you know knows how to uh turn
on the bigot spigot and we like shiv
because we like shiv and we want a woman
to be smart in this world and and we
like sarah snook's performance and she
has some outside experiences whatever
whatever sarah sue today was like you
know she has not
been in the much as the as much in the
conversation because i think in a lot of
ways it was roman season and karen
culkin's season and that jeremy strong
obviously
had a lot of very big showcasey scenes
towards the end of the season
but her in that room with frank and carl
and jerry and logan
she was
amazing in that scene yeah she was
savage i loved it i but i think that
just the idea that what they're fighting
for why they feel they are owed
something
if you take out the jargon
it's so dumb and petty and their dad
called them on it right like really
jargon when romans like
love roman's like love that's why you
should do this you owe us because we've
sat here and eaten [ __ ] for 30 years and
now you can just make another baby and
they get connored and by the way like
all of this was
sometimes it's one of the pleasures of
the show
is that there's so many scenes and
there's so many funny scenes that they
wash over you and they don't necessarily
feel like they are
um strung together in any particular way
um there's a version of watching this
episode and being like oh alan rock's
great and he finally got a big scene and
you know he's he's always he's a he's a
team player he's always around he's
always good for
you know a couple minutes uh in crunch
time
this scene was crucial not just to the
character development the scene at the
table the intervention for kendall
that's actually
a declaration
for conor
um
it's crucial because what it does is
foreshadow how all of this comes down to
nonsense birth order
right they don't hold anything in their
hands
except their last name which they don't
even hold because as logan says their
hands just turned to sausages
it it's it's pretty expertly done in
addition to being pretty funny and we
should shout out while we're just i
don't know if we're going to talk more
about conor but uh justine lupe's uh uh
face as the limo door is closing shouts
to mark milot for catching that you know
they have a lot of cameras moving they
probably did a bunch of takes but i mean
the
the quiet desperation of that shot of
little moments like that like i thought
jeremy's strong patting the valet on the
shoulder like the the guy bringing him
his car yeah as if he's sort of like
hey
we're good now right service industry
like i work in class i've unburdened
myself but just that little tap like him
watching those guys bringing out the
trash
yeah there were so many
great moments and i also thought
you know just the way in which
they shot that last confrontation of
logan
being like you know
going from
i'll be placating then i'll just try to
get roman and then when it's obvious
that the three of them have turned
against me
all hell breaks loose and at the end of
that scene and when you get to the end
of that
i thought the the [ __ ] best part
about it because sometimes for as much
as i love connor i i kind of wonder like
oh like conor's incredible but this is
kind of like a comic relief part for the
show it's like a pressure release valve
but at the end of that scene all those
kids are connor
they just got connored yeah they just
have this name now and now they have a
lot of money and they have like kind of
a nebulous sort of
you know role in the world but they have
no actual power and they have no actual
jews and i do think for as much as that
last scene was uh the godfather and
however much i
i keep using game of thrones as a hobby
horse to talk about the the maybe straw
men and women watching the show who
expect this succession to be like game
of thrones
i i wasn't kidding when i said it was
kind of like the red wedding um
the power dynamics at play in that room
were so complicated and so brilliantly
staged
the kids come running in with all the
steam
and brian cox doesn't stand up for a
very long time
now that is powerful acting
to be owning it all from a seated
lowered position but one of the things
that i kept thinking about while the
scene was was on was
playing out and you real and and
realizing how it was going and as the
characters the kids realize how it's
going
was that uh carl frank and jerry are all
in that room for all of it right they
are old hands
they have survived ten times as many
things as these kids have and they've
had to work for it in a completely
different way and they have lived with
their heads under the guillotine in a
real way uh for the entirety of their
professional careers
and
that factors into our watching of the
scene i bet it factored into the acting
of the scene and it was just so powerful
from a visual perspective it's like
you've had your [ __ ] fun dum-dums
the grown-ups
are now
just going to to drive they're going to
drive and they're sitting here and
they've been sitting here the whole
the whole time
so what else did we have have we not hit
i mean i thought that
watching the greg stuff over the course
of the episode and over the course of
the last few episodes
you would normally maybe just write that
off not unlike conor as a comic element
but i thought that if this season taught
us anything um aside from the fact that
you know you feel free to go swimming
after a couple of bronies uh it taught
us that this stuff happening on the
periphery is actually really important
so
greg uh perhaps becoming the weirdest
king in europe
who knows that's saying something by the
way but maybe that winds up coming into
play in some capacity do you know what i
mean like maybe all of the stuff i don't
think that that stuff gets written into
this show i think there are a lot of
throwaway lines and there are a lot of
freebies and there's a lot of really
great burns and sometimes you'll get a
joke that happens
at the expense of the drama or at the
expense of the this should happen after
this
but i'm curious what you where your head
is at with like some of the more
lower to your characters in terms of
like what their what their part is in
the great the great plan
well i'm happy for comfrey that she got
her trip to europe into italy i was
happy that frank and carl were there we
talked about that last week i'm relieved
um
i i i'm very i am interested in the i
mean we'll start with greg like
tom isn't lying to him
you know and and i i don't want to make
a blanket statement without you know i
haven't obviously re-watched the
entirety of the show we were just we
just recorded after the show ended yeah
but i mean the series beyond it because
i was going to say that i think that
i don't know if tom's never lied to greg
um but that might kind of be true right
like you know when he says who in this
family's looked out for you
he's right
he's dealt with him he engages with him
he [ __ ] on him and he made him eat an
ordellon with a napkin over his face
among any other many other indignities
but laughed at him when he did like a
table full of cocaine to save cancer
but he but he talks to him sure you know
he engages with him and that is clearly
enough um
which other characters should we should
we run through yeah i mean we could talk
about caroline i mean this was uh two
episodes of where she sort of loomed in
the background
and uh
i wondered for a while like what aside
from the incredible
trip they must have gotten out of it
like where are we going with this not in
like a nagging way but i was just sort
of like
that scene with shiv
and you're my onion in episode 8 of
you know what and and also sort of
caroline's view on what those kids
needed
and and even her saying like maybe this
is best for for all of you maybe this
has all gotten a bit crazy
i mean
they are extremely bad
parents they don't love them or express
love in any way that is sustaining or
helpful in any imaginable sense
and yet these kids
they hold out hope yeah they hold out
hope and hope can be very very very
dangerous you know they all look like
kick dogs at the end of it
and and i i think that there is a a a
yes and there's a version of
of this um
where you know just just the shiv stuff
they're just they they think the kids
keep thinking they've climbed to the top
of the highest point and they have now
the perspective to see what they did
wrong and how what it would take to get
to what to become what they most want to
be and i think
shiv leaving the onion conversation last
week and saying to tom you know here's
what we're going to do we're going to
show them we're going to get this right
and she didn't use those words she used
very different words but to herself i
think that was what she was thinking you
know i'm going to earn my mother's
respect by defeating her basically and
being better than her and being having
it all
to her comment her now you know darkly
uh almost darkly comically foreshadowing
comment to her mother at the wedding
when she's like i hope that your wedding
is as supportive and loving your
marriage as as mine i forgot that that's
minutes before before all of this
happens
you know um
they
i i think that that's what i keep coming
back to
what's so appealing and engaging about
the show is just the kind of really
uncomfortable naked humanity of it that
these people who have everything
keep coming back to the one thing that
they actually want and they cannot get
it but they cannot accept it right um
logan and matt's and understand each
other there's the dialogue about
everything is boring
except this
except the high of this
of this moment and it's kind of
interesting what it means for logan
going forward
is that you know all this talk about him
aging or being ill or lying in winter or
raging against the dying of whatever not
bowing to reality
he might just straight straight spitting
maca root everywhere he goes
but regardless of that that that feels
like a distraction because it might be
that at in the you know that [ __ ]
rented palazzo that that matson doesn't
have a bed in logan might have been like
oh no i get it this is it this is my
last high and i'm gonna make it pure and
i'm gonna make it good
and this is it and at the end i'll have
more money to throw on top of my pile of
money but i don't give a [ __ ] about
money i don't care it doesn't matter but
i'm going to have one last good time
basically one thing to feel alive and
that
i'm not going to say that's poignant
because in the next scene he tells his
children what he really thinks of them
which is that they're [ __ ] morons
right um
but there is something kind of kind of
it's not noble but it's pure but in that
is such an interesting example of how
sometimes what's interesting about
what the characters are doing in any
given moment is not always what's most
interesting about the show do you know
what i mean that there's a tension there
so
logan feeling the thrill of the deal
and recognizing recognizing in matson a
kind of
a fellow traveler when it comes to
i like failure and i like that you know
show me your weaknesses and like he's
when he's like what are you thinking and
logan's like i'm not [ __ ] telling you
what i'm thinking now interestingly
roman has a very similar response to a
question like that in episode 8 which
does speak to roman's similarity with
logan but
logan being sort of deposed as and you
know this show is going to figure it out
and next season he could be overseeing
the presidential election and that would
be a fascinating season of television or
whatever they want to do but logan not
being in this position is in some ways
as a dramatic return as a character
death as a main character does yes
you're right so i think that
we both
take away anything from the bravery of
the show even if i
think that i was feel caught up in the
momentum of oh my god like this is the
tragic end for this character this
unloved unlovable person i think it's
worth repeating yet again that
a hallmark of british tv maybe british
culture maybe british life is an ability
to withstand the most the cringiest most
uncomfortable situations
cringe comedy whatever that term might
mean
that
came to america
on the old shipping routes you know what
i mean like that came from that came
from the uk
and jesse armstrong cut his teeth on
comedy
i he's very very comfortable
hanging out in the next moment in the
moment after
um
and i think that the the way that
seasons break and the way the off season
happens
is really good for the show and for
american audiences because we could
leave season two with this rush of oh
kendall's coming for the king baby it's
gonna be team kendall versus team logan
let's [ __ ] go let's get ready to i'm
not gonna say cause i think we have to
pay that that dude a trademark fee if we
say it but you know what i mean
and then how does the next season begin
baby kendall's having a panic attack and
a bathtub
and we're gonna hang out with that panic
attack for eight more [ __ ] episodes
you know
that's that's what motivates him he
doesn't flinch he doesn't care like if
we get the chance to talk to him about
it i bet he's excited for the moment
after the moment when logan's like
everything is empty this is boring what
the [ __ ] that's what i was going to ask
you is we've talked a little bit about
the the
opening
set of episodes from this season pretty
much happened right after the end of the
second season right after episode one
episode two starts with shiv in the car
going back so there was this compression
and then
it kind of stretched out with maybe
weeks or whatever going on in between
episodes uh as as we hit the second half
i'm not asking for any to get any like
predictive and what do we want from
season three i don't really care yet i'm
curious whether or not you're more
curious about
what happens immediately as tom comes up
behind shiv and puts his hands on her
shoulders or six months later
when logan's like ah this isn't that fun
i'm gonna do i'm gonna cause a lot of
yeah like are you more interested in the
thing that happens the second after
logan leaves that room or a year after
logan leaves that room a year personally
a year i i think that this moment served
its purpose
and then i'd love to see the fallout you
know
i i was joking before when i mentioned
uh the office but you know
i feel like that
it is ripe for a michael scott paper
company type arc you know where like
shiv and kendall start their own media
empire yeah
well they said they would have
a beautiful partnership they were like
we could all be equals you know i mean
they'll borrow a van from the korean
church so they'll have to pick up people
all the time like in that episode but
but yeah i i i i would love to see a
time jump but i also
you know this is maybe this is old age
maybe this is just enjoying the show for
what it is but i feel i i feel
relatively zen about this in a way that
i might not have with one of the more
amped up plot driven masterpieces that
we've been referring to breaking bad
game of thrones like
you know i i
unlike kendall at the end of season one
at shiv's wedding like i trust the
driver here you know what i mean and
this
if there's one thing that this season
has shown us for good and for ill yeah
um
the show is going to do it's going to
operate on its own pace and tell the
stories that it wants to tell and it's
not going to
give us the satisfaction that we
sometimes want out of it or the or the
propulsive change that we sometimes feel
we deserve
it's going to pick the moment and it's
going to continue and
um
you know i i think that the the shape of
the series at least in terms of our
conception of it hasn't changed too much
by by this episode i still feel like we
are market capped at four or five
episodes max four or five seasons max
you know i i don't think there's
certainly nothing in this that suggests
uh
more than that but i also think that it
will play itself out to the end
as a family drama first and foremost and
the structure of the family and the
relationship to each other's family
but it's exciting i think that
what what is richer terrain for this
show with these actors and these writers
uh going forward is it
mourning the loss of kendall or logan on
trial for abetting the the cover-up of
the death of the boy
you know as he keeps calling him the the
cater waiter
um
no
what's most exciting going forward is
these actors and these writers
navigating what comes after this moment
when the it's not just the
the throne that was promised to them
being taken away the throat it doesn't
even exist anymore there's nothing
family has been broken up broken apart
into a hundred pieces yeah so what is it
so what is family what do they have to
do with each other now
that's interesting to me they have to
scale the north face of the [ __ ] iger
uh i have
like i guess the only thing i was gonna
say is if there's anything from uh
taking notes on this episode i have
i have uh roman's face during shifts
toast i really liked
yeah the face he makes when she makes
reference to her her marriage to tom but
also shiv by the way respect to shiv for
i i know she's the character not the
actress has gotten some criticism for
just
more than the others like
not just keep making the same mistakes
but
constantly constantly making the same
like uh turning blank dick into an
insult right sure like she she she seems
to have uh
in in her merriam-webster insult
dictionary she has her favorite page
highlighted yes yes
but there's something effective about
her sledgehammer approach to uh
belittling people because the sheer
savagery that she before she gets to the
room with her dad
when every other comment every other
sentence to her brother is you want to
[ __ ] our mother right when when
caroline's walking down the aisle and
she's just like you should go up and
tell mom yeah
yeah that was pretty good um i i you
know other than that it's just random
straight lines you're in in their make
your own [ __ ] pile pretty much sums
up logan's uh attitude towards his
children i have that underlined too what
am i going to do with the soul anyway
pretty much sums up all the characters
on this show
yeah
i think all of the stuff that kendall's
character
utters in that village scene where he's
you know like i'm you know i'm breaking
apart and shattered into a million
pieces and i'm so lonely and all those
things that almost sound sentimental or
melodramatic when you hear them read
back by me were just rendered incredibly
poignantly by jeremy strong
and uh yeah i also like like the line of
the wizard of [ __ ]
i want to stay in that dust for a while
by the way
the costumers did a great job because
or maybe rich people just know how to
get like you know uh the famous red soil
of sienna out of thousand dollar pants
during a car ride because bravo that was
that was very well done um
i i think to me that was the most
thrilling scene not just because it was
so momentous emotionally but
because of what it did do and what it
didn't do you know i
i
this is a broken record we we're
recording
basically instantly and so i'm sure
there are more things to say about the
episode in different places too that we
could have we could have uh we could
have dived deeper into
but
i just think that so many shows um
will take the opportunity for a
character being at rock bottom whether
they're actually saying i'm not a good
person or not
to
bring closure to that emotional moment
so what you would expect in a lesser
show or a less interesting or
intelligently written show would be for
kendall to wipe his eyes and stand up
and be a new man he has unburdened
himself he's reborn if he quote unquote
died at the end of the last episode but
that's just not what happens in life and
this show is not life but what happens
when people break down in the dust near
a trash can is people are like uh do we
have to do this yeah seeing
seeing people cry is hard it sucks it's
uncomfortable you see it every monday
and thursday with me
well luckily they turn off the zoom
cameras but kaya has the tapes um
and then it was just time for him to get
up he laughed once
you know about the gin and waiting 45
minutes for a gin and tonic and that was
a human moment but life isn't just one
moment you know yeah and it and then it
and then it was on to the next thing
because the people around him were onto
the next thing and he was great sadly
and this came across in jeremy strong's
performance i think kendall was grateful
for the crumbs
i think he was happy to be given
something to do as he says he's been
planning this since he was four so i
think he was i think he was grateful for
the attention he got yes the emotional
he he knows they're all broken sock
puppets you know and so he got a he got
as much as they were capable of giving
and maybe that was okay for a moment and
then yeah
and then there was an updraft and he
could just stand up and glide on it
again for a minute and maybe maybe for
him that's as good as it gets it it is a
it is a savage show i was emailing with
someone else who was who was
you know expressing strong opinions
about what would happen and and he said
uh this is ghost i know if botch goes
ghost doesn't have wi-fi this was this
was an email and
basically saying but it is someone who
works in the industry and was basically
saying
this is the most violent show i've ever
watched in my life
and i and i kind of love i kind of love
that yeah that is that is a good way of
looking at it it's funny to think about
that in relationship to like squid game
and mayor of kingstown but yeah yeah
and i think that you know
this show confounds us in a number of
ways and is it like de facto the number
one show of the year is it the best show
on television is it everyone's favorite
is it the most popular it's kind of no
to all of those it has become
the most exciting to watch on mass in a
way that you and i love and podcast
listeners love and is super fun
um
but it isn't always the very best you
know it but it is absolutely true to
what it is in such an engaging
uh creative [ __ ] cerebrally smart um
and often hilarious way that i i
[ __ ] celebrate it and i've loved
doing this and talking about it week to
week i'm gonna miss it not many shows
um
you know we're gonna do our best of the
tv pod next week best tv of the year pod
um i know the show will be high up for
both of us it might not be number one
because it might not do all of the
things that we love or that we're
looking for the best of anything right
yeah but in terms of giving us the
opportunity to do to do this and talk
about stuff and dig i mean there is
nothing better right now and i'm
i'm i'm pretty excited about it still
and grateful for it i'm always bummed at
the end of a season or succession
because it means i can't talk about it
every week with you so uh thank you to
you uh thank you chris if you were here
i would touch your head kind of
awkwardly
and then go take a selfie you know i'll
be your pod sporus whenever you need um
by the way i don't know if this is true
uh if there are people who have found us
or only listening to us during these
succession pods but i would just like to
say stick around i just feel like our
new ceo lucas matson has a lot of great
ideas
i feel like our churn rate hasn't been
great going you know in the past but i
feel like in fiscal 22 it's going to
turn around and i feel like we've got a
lot to offer thank you to kai mcmullen
for producing and for sticking around
late on a sunday night to produce this
thanks to everybody for listening to our
succession recaps this season we'll be
back on thursday with uh normally
scheduled programming and we've got our
best tv of the year podcast with sams
mail coming next week so
fun stuff on the watch feed stick around
and we'll talk to you guys soon he says
i'm not a good person and roman says
you're fine
you're fine that's what it is man that's
life
[Music]
you